welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss here with Tommy Vector that's how
you say I'm excited and Wookie baby
because we got new games
thought it was I love you it is it's the
same it's a unit it's like Aloha it's a
low end goodbye and I love you well this
is a breakdown of some details you
missed in the new trailer for Jedi
Survivor the follow-up to Jedi Fallen
order from EA Games in relation to eat a
Voss it's coming March 17 2023 eat a
floss it's in the video that's my that's
my impression all right this is a
Gameplay trailer showcasing calcus's
fighting style with a few cameos of
droids and Aliens while keeping things a
mystery as to who Tank Man is but we
have a theory about this fella don't we
because that's what we do here let's
comb through this and break down what
you might have missed the order is gone
I was betrayed
by the one I trusted most
I will not be imprisoned again okay we
start again with our mystery Tank Man
from the earlier teaser or former Jedi
who has been imprisoned in a back to
tank actually later in the trailer he is
wearing gold and white robes making us
think he might come from the high
Republic era which would mean he's been
frozen in his tank for hundreds of years
whatever his grievances are they're with
someone long dead before the return of
the Sith now this might tie in with the
acolyte we just started to see early
Snap photos of Daphne Keane and Dean
Charles Chapman now Jedi Survivor is
gonna be March 17th it's right in the
middle of the Mandalorian season three
Fallen order came out the week of the
mandalorian's first season premiere in
November 2019 and obviously much of
lucasfilm's designs for the inquisitors
and the Fortress inquisitorious and
Obi-Wan Kenobi were reused from that
game that's right Jedi Survivor is going
to take place five years after Jedi
Fallen order roughly around the same
time as the Obi-Wan Kenobi series come
on get kestus in live action babe right
but based on tank man's pale skin I
think he might be the cage species from
the world of forzai this was from Clone
Wars episode 20 Bounty which featured
asajj Ventress on an underground train
job with a race that looked a lot like
this but with eye colors other than blue
but you know there could be a lot of
different ones all right come on give me
some more of that footage
[Music]
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
[Music]
we get to see more of cowcaster's
gameplay here and it looks like he has
retained most of his skills in force
Knowledge from the end of Fallen order
which is good because I can't relearn
that his lightsaber postures have
expanded we'll know who uses single
wheel to do a wield and a double-ended
dual wield and he gets a new lightsaber
with a cross guard yeah actually in this
section he locks Savers with someone
with an orange or yellowish saber and
that one has side pieces that flip down
on the side for that cross guard so
maybe this is the hilt that he takes and
he changes the kyber crystal within it
it's like the face razors that used to
have the Sideburn trimmer that you'd
flip down right like get a little extra
something for you here but that's where
they get you where you got to get the
extra component to reach oh then you
need an extra brush and all of a sudden
you're asking your dad why do we shave
anyway and your dad says we're
genetically hairy at one point kale
lifts a stormtrooper to shoot the others
and then drops him the slash at his back
which I gotta say feels like Kale's
breaking a little bad here feels a
little dark sidey to me yeah but I love
up to see it I mean is it really count
in that point or is it yeah is it the
person who's playing that's right the
guy doing the gameplay footage was like
feel evil today yeah
they're crimes anyway well at least one
new skill set Cal will learn in this
game is going to be some Jedi animal
Taman relatively new poor skill to Star
Wars can and you know where Jedi just
can't have this Francis the CC Vibe
going on yeah some areas may only be
accessible it looks like by riding a
mount or hanging from a flying animal
cow catches up with seerjundo who was
previously on a mission to rebuild the
Jedi Order we're gonna see here she's
surrounded by Blue glowing Stacks that
look like Jedi archive Stacks curated by
jacosta new yeah they do look pretty
similar now there is no side of the
death of Marion Marin in this trailer I
thought she might be that person wearing
the veil besides here I'm not really
sure but when Cal pilots and crashes of
mantis we don't see Marin or Greece with
him let's watch more yes
foreign
remind our friend here why is God and
are supposed to be dead
here we go
whoa here Cal meets two new characters
presumably bounty hunters the big alien
looks like a Jedi like dirge which we're
believed to be unkillable yeah behind
him the orbit sign translates to dendras
Antiquities so like Lutheran shopping
and or this could be another Trove of
Star Wars Easter eggs yeah I'm gonna be
that guy that everybody hates the game
with it just walks around and closes in
and zooms Now by this point in the video
it should be pretty obvious how freaking
excited Tommy and I are to play should I
Survivor but you know that's going to
mean a lot of time staring at calcast
with his perfect CGI hair in his skin
and if you're too busy making yourself
the Empire's most wanted to get into the
weeds of your skincare routine you
should try geology
geology is a 15-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast birdie Men's
Health Esquire ask men grooming Awards
the Tom Bechtel digest one of those is
fake with over 6 000 five-star reviews
and they've recently expanded to offer
products or for pretty much whatever you
need yeah all you got to do is take a
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology figures out your routine for you
it's funny I took that quiz and they
identified that it was my fault in all
of my relationships as well thank you
geology I took that quiz and they also
said it was Tommy's fault all the
problems were in my relationships now if
you need Hair Care use geology's co-wash
a specially formulated cream cleanser
that removes buildup and cleanses the
hair without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo and for
the rest of your shower routine you can
use their body washes they're free of
harsh ingredients they smell great and
they are refillable and what about after
the shower Eric protect your skin from
environmental stressors the vitamin C
plus e feralic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy I'm a baby and
then a bit of Dermatology tested
aluminum free deodorant that quite
honestly smells delightful I haven't
gotten any complaints and that's because
I live alone right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely insane offer if you
use the code new rockstars they will
give you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stocking instead either way
geology has you covered check out their
awesome gift sets featuring all of your
favorite geology products to get started
just click the link in the description
take a 30 second diagnostic quiz and
their team of dermatologists will design
a personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door dang let's
watch a little bit more of this
[Music]
done
the Empire has only grown stronger
boom cow face is a variant of a Whopper
but not a snow Whopper like we saw an
odd this is a jungle Wampa which feels
problematic now they say it out loud
these showed up in Star Wars the Old
Republic and they are adapted for warmer
climates I just love how he ragdoll's
cow like Hulk with Loki yes he gets a
filthy puny Jedi we fight a DT series
Sentry Droid from Star Wars Rebels
straight out these were the precursors
to the dark Troopers we saw in the
Mandalorian season two which quite
frankly gave me nightmares the ones Luke
Skywalker makes mints made of as he
saves grogu come on more trailer
[Music]
thanks bud
part of the job guesses
all right we need a new character this
smoke show is named Bode and this planet
behind him could be narshada That's The
Smuggler's Moon that the Huts Clan
operate it could be dyu remember that
Hong Kong inspired planet or you know
Obi-Wan rescued Leia from an Obi-Wan
Kenobi there were lots of neon orabesh
rooftop signs here that's true and the
one here behind him ends in r b and o on
the top line beneath that it's g i can't
make sense of it this guy can't
translate everything well it's it's
awesomely the body is blocking those
letters boom thick boy bone rolls over
his back and gets a boost which is how
you and I like to hop over fences at
outdoor concerts thank you Counting
Crows we didn't pay a dime to See You
Gonna Be A Long December for your bank
accounts let's keep yeah I apologies the
Jedi is a threat
now that we have this
as long as we fight
[Music]
okay so tank man tells that gendai
bounty hunter that Cal isn't a threat
now that they have this artifact and we
actually saw this same object in Cal's
hand earlier when he released Tank Man
from that back to tank so what do we
think it is could it be something
connected to the bathroom Obi-Wan Kenobi
some records of the surviving Jedi that
are still out there simple oh I hope so
let's find them and kill them no no I
must resist all of this the battle
droids the cow fights have similar red
plating to the armor worn by the Jedi
making me wonder if he programmed them
to work for him oh on to the last part
Eric finish his own baby hope survives
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
slashing through some KX series droids
Cassie and Andor could use some of those
against those on the Amos you know there
are no lightsabers allowed or hey
remember when luton's founder hallcraft
beamed out those red lasers from the
sides yeah they're all like oh my gosh
Lutheran a Jedi confirmed because we all
those lightsaber boners
no just because someone has lasers and
seems to be a good pilot doesn't make
them easy come on don't simp for
lightsabers be a man and wait for it
like me wait for marriage well we are
super excited to play this game on March
17th 2023 is going to be a big year for
Star Wars we got bad batch Mandalorian
season three Ahsoka Jedi Survivor and
more details about the Acolyte and
skeleton crew Wikileaks is not dead
we're just sleeping but we've woken up
to do this trailer breakdown here come
on Eric send us home one last ride in
2022 and we will be back in 2020.
believe me trust us Eric we're hoes
follow Tommy at Tommy BEC told follow me
[Music]
it's on the video follow new Rockstar
subscribe to your rockstars or
breakdowns of everything you love come
on give it to me one time for Old Times
Sake we have spoken bye later
[Music]